good morning y'all welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel today
I have morning water thoughts um because
you guys all roasted me
in the last video because I was drinking
sugary coffee and then you're like
well if you want to lose weight why
don't you stop drinking the coffee so I
was like you know what instead of taking
offense I was like you're right
so I've gone like three days without
coffee
and I bought a giant water bottle to
cope so today
we're talking about the whale attacks
again
but this time legally so I woke up this
morning
to a complaint actually it was from an
hour ago which was not morning but I
wake up late so hi just pearly things
this is to notify you that you have
received a privacy complaint from an
individual regarding your content
I'm like who would file that because
it's funny I always go up and say you
want to do an interview for YouTube
and people can say yes or no
so so the other day in shortage when the
when the whale attacked I said do you
guys want to do an interview
and then they said yes or no and they
they said yes right
they do the interview and then the lady
starts like Loki trying to attack me
like literally like out the footage
drops tonight at 5 30 okay 5 30. you'll
see this woman starts trying to like
literally come at me and I'm like ma'am
if you if you don't
want to do this anymore you can get out
of the shot but but I need you to like
move back this woman will not like not
only
not only
did she consent to the interview she
refused to leave
um
like she wouldn't literally kept getting
in the shot she kept getting in the
camera's way I'm like it's crazy because
if you really didn't want the attention
you would think you would get out of the
shot but this is how whales work this is
how whales work they take no
accountability for anything in their
life nothing nothing and they will give
you consent and take it back and that's
why I don't just automatically believe
women
because look at look at what This
Woman's doing here she
is playing the victim
and I and I swear to God I've had this
happen more than once where I will
have girls come on my show they don't
like the way that they don't like the
Public's response to the words they
chose to say
they chose to say
and so what happens
then they get mad at me I'm like people
I don't make you do anything like whale
whale this is to you this is to you I
didn't make you
aggressively come at me
I didn't make you knock the mic out of
my hand I didn't make you call me a slag
I didn't make you
I didn't make you threaten to fight me
okay I didn't make you do any of that
I've interviewed people left and right
and have zero issues with them
zip none nasiki they do a great great
interview and they leave but you ma'am
you chose to be insane on camera after
you consented
and that's exactly what I'm gonna tell
YouTube and I have a whole 10 minute
interview
proving this I have everything on camera
so good luck do what you want
and
that's the crazy thing men don't do this
it's only women I've had men go viral
for the wrong reasons too okay
I've had men get hate on my channel they
never complain it's only the women why
because women and especially feminists
they are never held accountable for
anything their whole life and so when
they do an action it has a consequence
they're so used to being bailed out of
freaking everything being an [ __ ] and
being bailed out of it that they they
need someone to blame because they sure
as hell can't blame themselves
foreign
probably a decade younger than this
[ __ ] like I and you're gonna threaten
me on camera and then get mad at me at
me for the actions that you chose to do
and going viral for the wrong reasons
and this is this is the [ __ ] feminine
and this is why guys you can't just
openly believe women it is the same
thing with consent
ah and what are they gonna say like that
they were drunk
I'm sorry I've been drunk before I don't
drink anymore but I at one point in my
life I used to drink and the [ __ ] I did
when I was drunk was my own damn fault
if you if you rob someone and you're
drunk
did you not Rob them
and this is
oh my God this is a crazy thing
so
the whale attacks
um we would like to so I get two days to
hear from YouTube because
like this is insane um
this is the thing guys
women deserve to be held accountable
this [ __ ] is not okay and the crazy
thing is these same women in the same
utterances of threatening me will talk
about how men are dangerous men are the
problem but when I go out the only time
I've ever been scared in my life and I
guys I'm not a super conflict heavy
person I know I argue with people on the
channel but I'm not I've never in my
life wanted to throw hands more than I
did at this girl because I've never in
my life felt threatened I mean honestly
the whale though like
ah
I was like [ __ ] I could just do a light
Jog and you couldn't keep up
to God I don't ever get fat you know
what if I ever do you guys could call me
a will too and I'll be like you know
what you're right you're right but
seriously like
they don't get held accountable for
anything and in the same utterances they
will talk [ __ ] about men when they're
the problem they're the issue when
you're the one that is harassing a young
woman you're threatening a young woman
who is just trying to do her job
and you're afraid of men and these are
the same girls in the interview they say
oh let's not stroke the man eat man's
ego and that they're talking they're
literally pointing at my camera guy
saying are you gonna are you gonna greet
me are you gonna greet me what am I
gonna look at every woman now Terry
you're gonna assault me are you gonna
call me a slag are you gonna threaten me
no because I'm not I'm not I can think
I'm I I have a thinking capability I'm
not saying I'm the sharpest tool in the
shed but I can tell you I can think I'm
smarter than a five-year-old and I swear
to God these half these [ __ ] are not
because I can understand that one just
because one person does something
doesn't mean that everyone's gonna do it
but whales anyways
so
um beware of whale attacks they've been
becoming more and more common
um they'll attack you and then blame you
um honestly the
the government should
n't be whale of Beware of land whale
attacks
um honestly I should make a sign
that would be so funny
the picture of her beware of land
oh my God I'm gonna cry
so freaking funny anyway so beware um
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
let me know your thoughts okay
was I wrong
was I wrong don't forget to like the
video subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time bye